when did you stop doing it 22 years ago
Wow 23 yeah Wow yeah that's a good
amount of time well I had to you know I
was doing this movie and I finished the
guy I had throw this guy through a wall
and I really liked the guy you know and
and I didn't want to hurt him and he
said no no you know so I put him through
the wall and took a door off the hinges
and they said honey we don't own that oh
this is whitey Bulger's place I go hey
I'm done after today someone's gonna pay
whitey so the guy I got I finished and I
bought a bag blow and whiskey and a bag
of dope and some beers and guys you're
happy that I see guys you want to get
real happy I said you don't scare me so
we'll pick you up at 6:00 a.m. so I went
back to the hotel I met my buddy my
childhood buddy we went out he said
let's see how many bars we can go to
before they charge us for bulls you know
yeah so we ended up at the Tall Ships
down at the Fanueil Hall and the guy
didn't know me so we paid we said we'll
stay here then he realized who I was
then we drank free went back and we're
doing blowing the door bangs open we go
freaks out he said what he said so guys
come on we're going we're going to like
a rave and he took me to a meeting in
South Boston and I just it clicked you
know I thought it was a gag I said I
ride the blow with me and it's come on
ones in the line just listen listen
listen
after a bender after a but what during a
Penta on me and I I thought it was a
brave I don't know you know with that
culture it might feel bad or no he was
he's still my sponsor today you know how
and he's a young kid
and you know I said you get some bleep
did you have a problem he says I used to
go into banks for the shock but everyone
on the floor I go yeah you can be my
sponsor Wow best thing Joe we got sober
together yeah they're not the same day
oh wow yeah Wow 23 years yeah yeah it's
that was a thing about that whole Boston
cruise it it was all kind of tied to
drugs oh and the comedy had that feel to
it
because the comedy was frantic you know
and it was a thing yeah bang bang bang
there was a thing about the guys who
came out of Boston like still to this
day they had like tough
fastest pace the most punchlines and the
audience is there were used to that on
any [ __ ] and they would tell you
yeah that would if you weren't good you
suck tonight get off and we would have
but it was there were times let's say
this is gonna be new material my night
anyone who doesn't do new material the
minute you do anything you've done
before get off the stage so Raj sniff
he's sitting at the back and some you've
done that mean Jo shot glass would
shatter in a while look next it was this
magical and the people they like you
said the audience's that came in there
would come every week you know so you'd
have to get and they would not settle
for any [ __ ] you know that blows
that's no good yeah there was a there
was a whole scene there wasn't just the
comics it was like comedy connoisseurs
there were so many people that came to
those clubs this shows pull it up Mike
it shows that with legendary will the
ding ho on Wednesday night Lenny would
put like 32 acts on all I'd go and you
know we gotta get the show over guys you
want to give a break to guys going on
till 2:00 in the morning and the liquor
license that the cops are couple and you
got you got a stop and I go have a drink
and we'll finish up you know first the
first night he took over when kremens
left Kermit's was leaving and there was
a Jesus job 85-86 so we round I thought
it closed at 84 I could be wrong on the
I don't know it was sure close before my
I came in 88 you know you know what
you're right probably probably around 84
I took over from Barry and so suddenly
says to me hey man babby Schlieffen will
you stay for me I'll double your pay and
I go yeah all right I'll stay about 15
to 30 dollars right at the time you know
and he says you you run the club I go
haha man I'll get a guy he goes so it
goes but a little brother who just got
laid off and Paul the right to go well
what if he screws us I said if he screws
us I'll tell my mother will be fine so
he comes in and the first thing he says
this [ __ ] is right the food sucks
close the backroom close the restaurant
we're gonna make that a show room - so
you're open the front room you go
through the kitchen and do a show in
back room then you come back to him wait
till it and we started we're doing six
shows tonight but the first night he
comes in I was pretty little because
you're not going on tonight you're drunk
and I go [ __ ] you man but I just got you
the [ __ ] job you [ __ ] you I'll do
whatever I want bla bla bla
so he gets Gavin and they go come on man
let's go in the cool the roads all night
so under cool it was doing lines and
cowgirls I'll be right back I go on I
apologize okay you all right but he
turned it into a gold mine we'd be doing
six shows a night three in the front
three in the back when Sweeney said that
the guy lost it in a gambling yeah yeah
play Chinese dominoes over in Chinatown
and he didn't pay his food tax and so I
guess a year and a half later they came
and locked it up but well first they
came and he would send a kid out to a
liquor store to buy booze because they
took all the booze so we'd have to buy
booze for that night and then after that
they they came and they took the chairs
they took the tables it was it yeah I
lost every but it was Wednesday night
Lenny Thursday night DJ has it
Friday night Don Gavin Saturday night
kremens and Sweeney on Sunday night
oh just killer show and what people
don't know is that Boston had a
different way of doing it so if it was
the Lenny Clarke show Lenny would host
the show right when he would go on he
would do like what 10 15 minutes like
that was supposed to hit open with 40
you know what I came up with that joke
that was my idea because yeah because it
used to be you know open and mid like
closer yeah and I was always the closer
I'm going hey man if I could host it I
can do lines and smoke between the guys
and I said well if someone has a bad
said I could pick it up or I came here
no be the buffer while let's take it
over that guy good and it just took off
it was a great way of doing it yeah it
really was and then you would kind of
close it too right yeah oh yeah oh
absolutely yeah I mean you know it would
for 90 different crowds to like GAF i
chi I was always working Wednesdays and
I'd be other clubs in but I was
wondering what Cavs shoka's GAF had a
great show and they didn't like me I was
like calves crowd did not go for me they
hated me a nice what the you know I mean
it was a hold and I had to learn to
adapt to different audiences because
what was the difference between Garon's
crowd used to say it was more they were
smart he was a smart [ __ ] oh
yeah yeah yeah
he's a genius oh man his [ __ ] comedy
was so sharp he would have punchlines
you never saw coming topper punch lines
you never saw it you were comfortable
from the last punch line they hit you
with another Wow
yeah it was uh the first time I saw him
he came on and I watched him and I said
to master shot I don't like it but those
guys my first time I mean you know
[ __ ] lying
yeah because well not off to a good
start right like it was like competitive
here was well competitive and one night
I was doing a show with him and some guy
came on stage behind me he was coming
behind me and gavel this railing and
scored the guy off and I said em and I
was pretty cool because I got you
backing him we will drove home to his
place and it was like three days get
high and we've been friends ever since
but it's funny because he said to me
it's lucky I gotta ask you a question
because if you could be the richest
person or the most famous person what
would it be so but I was out the most
famous singers really yes okay six weeks
later SCAF I thought about it you're
right I'd rather be the richest the fame
shit's a bunch of [ __ ] he goes well
I'm glad you came around see what I mean
by smarter yeah he's nuts
yeah if you're the most famous person
you're just gonna get stalked every oh
it's not about that you'd rather be that
dude that nobody knows well of course
yeah you know I am I have five billion
difference billion and not million a
billionaire friends yeah I think I might
dip you know you know that pet pet pet
project you know but I mean it's
unbelievable I mean that to live like
that you let your billion say that none
of so it's these guys are just like that
more money than you could spend more
than you could spend yeah that's a weird
life yeah we're
like where everybody else is struggling
and but no one knows don't you have
enough but some of them people know you
know but these people are like anonymous
and if more money that you could have
just very clever God so yeah that's oh
that's what I would like that